[Music]
the United States especially has been
now custom for 25 years as being the
universal and unitary superpower that's
not gonna last forever
I think most people know this even
though some may be in cognitive
dissonance over this the truth is there
are rising powers like Russia and China
but there are other rising powers too
one of our problems is that we live in a
state centric view of the universe we
international relations for most of us
is run by States state nation states the
global political you know unit of the
international order and this is what we
learn in social studies as kids but that
is actually not the way the world has
worked for most of human history states
are actually about three or four hundred
years old before there were states or
empires and there were tribes and
everything else the the reign of States
and only states can wage war
legitimately that is coming to a close
we're actually going back to the status
quo ante of when global order was a
free-for-all
of like the Middle Ages of antiquity but
what became before and one of the things
of that for all is that who else were
superpowers it wasn't just States so
like in the Middle Ages
the papacy was a superpower rich
aristocracy's you know were superpowers
and we're going back to this world again
so you know that we have random
billionaires today who are of as much
power of States there are 62 people in
the planet who own the equivalent of
half the world's wealth sixty-two people
you can put them all into a bus you you
have you know multinational corporations
we have the fortune 500 which are more
powerful than most of the states in the
world
of the hundred ninety hundred ninety
four states in the world most are
fragile or failed we only think the top
25 states like the US Western Europe
eastern Asia etc but that's that's an
anomaly the map the vast majority of
states the world are
more either regimes hiding inside states
or just outright dumpster fires so what
we're gonna see in the future is those
who have wealth and political power who
can also hire their own private armies
now become superpowers the world used to
wage a lot of private war in military
history in fact most of military history
is privatized mercenaries have always
been a major component of war and what
happens when you privatize war is that
now military strategies blend with
business ones and this puts us at risk
because our four stars were in charge of
a military and our policy makers do not
they're not prepared for that type of
warfare
so mercenaries were around for millennia
Mercer brands are forever and it's
anomalous in history that 150 years ago
they sort of went away and why that is
is still a mystery
people say well after the 30 Years War
after the Peace of Westphalia of 1648
where mercenaries ran amok both rulers
and ruled were tired of them and and
Merton rulers and Kings started to
invest in their own standing armies
which is very expensive
I mean mercenaries are cheaper than
standing armies just like it's cheaper
to rent it than do than to own and
country's start to invest in large
national militaries or reasons for that
some of it was technological some of it
was political but they they've
monopolized the mark of the force over
the next some you know several hundred
years they pushed out mercenaries they
went underground by 1850 and we saw them
pop up around that the 1950s and 60s in
Africa during war as a decolonization
but there were always in the shadows now
they're returning and they're upfront
whether it's Blackwater for the United
States of America or the Wagner group
for Russia which is a powerful mercenary
corporation or executive outcomes in
South Africa in the 1990s we're seeing
nurseries come out of the shadows and
what can put them back in the shadows
well only one thing to do it
if all the nations the world got
together and band together as they did
in the 1600s 1700s and said no more
mercenaries which I think world peace is
easier so I don't think that's gonna
happen some people put their faith in
international public law the United
Nations the laws of war I am NOT one of
them as much as I would love to see that
happen the truth is is that
international law around war is it was
already very feeble and let's not forget
that mercenaries can shoot your law
enforcement they can shoot them dead
force is the only commodity that you
cannot regulate because it can resist
law enforcement and this is what makes
it so dangerous and by the way who's
gonna go into Syria and arrest all those
mercenaries now is it going to the
United Nations the US Marines I don't
think so
so I don't think laws the answer I think
the most we can do is we can shape the
market to incentivize good behavior and
blackballed bad behavior but the market
for force which has been with us through
all of human history had a it had a
brief hiatus but it's returning now and
we're not prepared for it it is one of
the biggest security threats of the 21st
century yet we're still focused on Isis
in some ways CEOs and Wall Street have
more to say about strategy in a future
of private warfare than does the
Pentagon and we're not prepared for this
so for example one of the things you
gotta think about private warfare as a
market for force with supply and demand
demand or clients supplier mercenaries
mercenaries don't want to work
themselves out of business they want to
start in elongate Wars for profit when
they're out of work they become bandits
creating artificial demand for the
services one of the things they do a lot
in the Middle Ages for example when
mercenaries were rampant is they would
get involved in racketeering and
extortion
for example a small private army of
mercenaries say five thousand
mercenaries shows up to a the city of
Siena and in
in Italy and they'd say we want 5,000
you know pounds of whatever we want
5,000 pieces of gold sort of making that
up and then the people Sienna would you
know run around and and say okay well
we'll give you all our gold just so you
don't sack us and you know take her
women and children and kill them kill us
all and the Mercedes would say thank you
we'll be back next year
right and so a world awash and
mercenaries is a world with more war and
the resurrection of private force is
symbolic and emblematic of durable
disorder because they'll keep persistent
conflict going they will contribute to
entropy and let's not also forget that
there are clients who do this as well so
you know you have random billionaire as
multinational corporations the
extractive industry will start to use
private forces to secure their our
people their assets whatever they want
to do or they can't wait to work for
whatever reason they want no matter how
petty the amount of how petty and having
mercenaries available in the world
meeting with money lowers the barriers
to conflict it makes going to war easier
and it makes stopping war harder
[Music]